Most recent labs show free T3 so the person is talking about this free T3 is a
thyroid marker so that's free T3 is your active thyroid hormone so it's at
the low end of range 2.0 and my free T4 is high outside of range and my ND said
she had never seen such high T3 T4 with low T3 without external supplementation to
drive up the T4. Well, I would say that your ND probably doesn't see a lot of
thyroid patients that because this scenario of high of low T3 and high free T4 is
called the under conversion effect so understand your thyroid gland makes over 90
percent of the hormone that the thyroid gland spits out is T4 which is not the
active form of the thyroid hormone the active form is T3 and it's free T3
understand that 90 percent the the T4 that and 10 percent T3 that's spit out by
the thyroid gland is also protein bound it's not even either one of them are in the
active form yet and then T4 is converted by an enzyme called 5di noase in the
liver and in the gut to become bound T3 and then the protein is shed and you have
active form of T3 so when a person has high free T4 and low free T3 that means
they're not converting T4 to T3 adequately that is that is usually the
possibilities of that that's again called under conversion effect it's not
converting T4 to T3 and it's usually because a person has Hashimoto's and they
may actually be attacking the 5di noase enzyme that converts T4 to T3 number
two they could have gut or liver issues so they're not producing that enzyme
and they're not getting the conversion so you have to look at antibodies in the
gut food antibodies typically that would cause that lead to lead to leaky gut
other things too so that's really this is called under conversion effect it's
very common with Hashimoto's I don't know I don't remember who asked this
question but you should make sure that you are getting TPO antibodies and
viral globulin antibodies tested to as well because pretty much guarantee that
if you don't know what already you have Hashimoto's disease so that is an
auto-immune thyroid she wanted me to check iron content of all my supplements but I
don't see anything significant there doesn't this look wacky to you as well any
ideas for cause so under conversion is caused from a person being in Hashimoto's
and they have an attack on the 5di noase enzyme or they don't have the
conversion going out of their liver or in their gut because liver had got
issues very common with Hashimoto's hey you know you can learn all about this in
this course right here this chronic disease I have module six oldest module is
all about Hashimoto's more than you ever